♪♪♪
>> MEGAN, YOU LOOK SO CUTE.
>> OH, THANKS.
JANELLE, WILL YOU LIKE FLUFF THE
BACK OF MY HAIR?
I FEEL LIKE IT'S GETTING FLAT.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> YOU GUYS, I LOVE HOW LIKE
WE'RE KEEPING IT SO CHILL THIS
YEAR.
>> I KNOW.
>> SO WE'RE JUST GRABBING DINNER
AND HEADING TO RYAN'S FOR A BIT.
>> YOU GUYS, LET'S DO A SELFIE.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, READY?
SMILE!
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE SUCH A
FUN NIGHT.
>> THIS NIGHT [ BLEEP ] SUCKS.
>> I GAVE MY CREDIT CARD TO
SOMEONE AND I DON'T HAVE IT.
WHO HAS IT?
>> PLEASE, HURRY UP, I NEED TO
GET PIZZA.
>> OH PIZZA BITCH.
>> HEY MEGAN WILL YOU DRAW MY
WHISKERS?
YOURS LOOK LIKE SO GOOD.
>> YES.
I DID A LITTLE WHITE LINE
UNDERNEATH FOR DEFINITION.
>> THAT'S SO SMART.
>> THAT'S HOW I WANT MINE TO
LOOK.
I'M GOING TO LOOK SO CUTE.
>> I'M SO UGLY.
>> DON'T SAY THAT.
>> MEGAN, DON'T, YOU STOP.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN A BITCH TO
ME ALL NIGHT --
>> THAT'S BECAUSE YOU WOULDN'T
WAIT.
>> NO, NO, YOU SAID TO GO.
>> SHOULD I PAINT MY NAILS
YELLOW?
>> OH, YEAH, YELLOW FOR THE
CHEESE.
>> IF YOU WANT TO BE A CAT TOO I
HAVE EXTRA.
>> THAT'S OKAY, I LIKE BEING THE
CHEESE.
>> WHY DID YOU MAKE ME BE THE
CHEESE?
YOU GUYS GOT TO BE CUTE AND YOU
MADE ME BE THE CHEESE.
>> AREN'T YOUR SHOES CUTE.
>> IT WAS SO HARD TO FIND GRAY
ONES THAT MATCHED.
>> PLEASE WAIT.
I GOT IT NOW.
WAIT FOR ME.
YOU GUYS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK I'M NOT GOING TO DRINK
TONIGHT.
>> GOOD IDEA, JANELLE.
>> THAT'S SO SMART, JANELLE.
>> OH MAN, WHAT UP, BABY?
YOU WANT SOME OF THIS?
>> THAT'S IT, YOU AND YOUR DRUNK
FRIENDS GOT TO GET OUT OF MY
RESTAURANT NOW.
>> NO.
>> YOU CANNOT YELL AT HER.
>> GET OUT OF MY STORE BEFORE I
TURN THE HOSE ON YOU.
>> OH, YEAH, YOU WOULD LOVE TO
DO THAT, YOU NASTY PERVERT.
>> NASTY PERVERT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SPOOKY.
>> WHAT THE HELL?
I LOOK CUTE.
>> TONIGHT WAS SO FUN.
>> YEAH.
I'M SO GLAD IT WAS JUST US
GIRLS.
>> HEY.
WHAT ABOUT ME?
>> OH, WHO LET THAT GUY IN?
>> I HAVE NO FRICKIN' IDEA.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]